good afternoon as you know the Federal
Open Market Committee this afternoon
reaffirmed the current zero to one
quarter percent target range for the
federal funds rate with economic
conditions improving and with further
improvement expected in the months ahead
we've again modified or forward guidance
in December in January the committee
judged that it could be patient and
beginning to normalize the stance of
monetary policy that meant that we
considered it unlikely that economic
conditions would warrant an increase in
the target range for the federal funds
rate for at least the next couple of
FOMC meetings well it's still the case
that we consider it unlikely that
economic conditions will warrant an
increase at the top in the target range
at the April meeting such an increase
could be warranted at any later meeting
depending on how the economy evolves let
me emphasize again the today's
modification of the forward guidance
should not be read as indicating that
the committee has decided on the timing
of the initial increase in the target
range for the federal funds rate in
particular this change does not mean
that an increase will necessarily occur
in June although we can't rule that out
it looks like from incoming data
pertaining to the first quarter that
real GDP growth has declined somewhat
below where it was for the last several
quarters of last year and that's really
why the committee indicated that growth
is moderated somewhat their hat there
has been a slight downgrading of
estimates of growth for this year you
mentioned the dollar we noted that
export growth is weakened probably the
strong dollar is one reason for that on
the other hand the strength of the
dollar also when part reflects the
strength of the US economy certainly
there are changes in the assessments of
the economy and forecast for the economy
that would point in the direction of
downward adjustment in the funds rate
path for one thing you do see meaningful
downward adjustment in the inflation
forecast certainly for this year in
additions importantly a number of
participants have marked down their
estimates of the normal longer run
unemployment rate so that range has
moved down noticeably from previously it
was 52 to 55 and it's now moved down
from 50 to 52 and downward revisions to
the longer-run normal unemployment rate
in a waist suggests that participants
are seeing more slack in the economy now
than they previously did